الان سوريا دخلت في ازمه جديده تتعلق
بالكوليرا دخلت حالات كوليرا ايضا للبنان
كيف تقيم لي الوضع السوري الان على
المستوى الانساني مع انه فتره طويله يعني
[موسيقى]
انا سعيد
لانك اثرتي هذا السؤال والحديث عنه لان
هذا
اساسيات وسوريا قد خرجت عن الجنده
من الاشياء التي تتحدث عنها في عقاب الحرب
احتياجات في اوكرانيا وفي اوروبا
اكثر من 133
الدوليه
في سوريا ايوه عذاب بصوره اساسيه الى
التلوث
وكذلك عملياتي
المكبات في نهر الفرات
بالاضافه الى ان النظام الصحيح في سوريا
لمده 10 سنوات قد لم يتضررون
فقط
في سوريا
ياسمين
الغربي اييي في سوريا
في سوريا
ويصلوا عددهم الى مليون
ولمن تركيه وصول الى الشمال غرب سوريا من
العراق وصول الى الشمال الشرق سوريا
[موسيقى]